now a US ship is standing by to evacuate
Americans from the northern Port of hia
in Israel to Cyprus us authorities have
not said how many will be taken on board
but they say space is limited and people
will be allowed on as they arrive tens
of thousands of US Passport holders live
in Israel since the War Began 29 have
been confirmed dead and 15 are missing
villain Mark has more from
hia since the early morning us officials
have been working with hundreds of
wouldbe passengers to get them
registered for this ferry that will take
them across the Eastern Mediterranean
towards Cyprus it's a 12-hour Journey
luggage has been limited by the
authorities here and there have been
some people we've spoken to complaining
about the lack of communication around
this evacuation effort people have been
waiting hours several of them with their
young children and very very slowly
they're being allowed over the foot
Bridge down towards the passenger Ferry
the capacity around 2,000 we've probably
seen just a few hundred so it doesn't
look like there's going to be as much
demand as perhaps us authorities
expected flights though important to
Note have been cancelled over the past
week or so many carriers suspending
their service out of Tel aviv's benorian
airport and so for some people we spoke
to here traveling to the US to Europe
this was an easy option particularly for
those in the North of Israel as a method
to leave the country in terms of their
thinking some of them incredibly torn
about the decision to depart many others
though saying this is the right time and
the right decision because of the fear
years of a future escalation even worse
than what we've already seen bam marks
aler Hyer Israel